they say it's a jungle out there
but they're wrong
it's a battlefield
with no geneva convention
these predators fight tooth and nail
using every weapon in their arsenal
camouflage
firepower even chemical warfare
they're some of the world's deadliest
predators
and they're locked and loaded
[Music]
for thousands of years the sentinels of
war have carried one weapon into
the indispensable weapon of birds of
prey
and their primary hunting
[Music]
sometimes the sharp talons kill at the
initial strike
and that may be the victim's best option
because if they're not killed outright
the town helps train the animal and
prevent escape
the toes squeeze strongly which can
cause death by asphyxiation
the squeezing may also force talons into
the flesh
vent the prey succumb since a loss of
blood or organ failure
[Music]
deep in the south atlantic life seems to
have
in the rocky outcroppings known as the
falkland islands a talent hunter
[Music]
the striated caracara
and allen's
juvenile handfuls gangs
[Music]
terrorize each other before wreaking
havoc on the rest of the island
[Music]
karakara is mainly scavenged
and they're not choosy
when elephant seals malt
the cars snack on dead skin
anything motorist they go for
but the for seal colony provides names
for the karakara
newborn pups
these moms go fishing hunting season
opens
and that's when this young caracara
learns how to use his talons
[Music]
the wrestling piles up a swarm of
switchblades
just as mother returns
[Music]
[Music]
calling to her pub brings no answer
[Music]
[Music]
no problem for the karakara
they can still find plenty of other food
to sink their talons into
seabirds are laying eggs
and caracaras have eagle eyes
now the talons double as hammers
[Music]
good protein for a carnivore
but even more when the eggs hatch
rockhopper penguins have given birth
this time the talons deploy for a ground
assault
[Music]
the talons grip the turf like a runner's
cleats
allowing karakaras to sweep in and steal
prey
[Music]
with its sure-footed talents
the caracaras can't be outrun here
or out fought
back at the nest the karakara has its
own young defeat
the next generation of knife wielders
[Music]
sonora desert arizona
this arid landscape is home to one of
north america's most enigmatic talent
hunters
the harris hawk
in this hostile habitat prey is scarce
and the harris hawks can't count only on
their talons if they want to survive
so they have adapted to the desert by
learning to hunt together the only hawk
to do so
in fact paris hawks exhibit the most
sophisticated cooperative hunting
tactics documented in birds more than
doubling their odds of a kill
they've set their eyes on a cottontail
rabbit
this rabbit is not an easy prey he is
fast and blends well with the desert
brush
the squad surrounds the target
to be successful the hawks will rely on
a tactic optimized for a long chase
the relay attack
the rabbit manages to shake one hawk off
but the others are right behind
[Applause]
like a wolf pack the hawks share their
catch
another unprecedented behavior among
birds of prey
[Music]
this mouse knows that he is no match for
the hawk out in the open
his defense a borough lined with thorns
for now the strategy pays off
knives work only in close quarter combat
so even the sharpest talons have their
limits
and when a knife won't cut it
toxins may be the answer
for humans chemical weapons are
relatively new tools of battle
but in nature
they've been around for millions of
years under a different name
venom
potency varies from predator to predator
they also inject their victims in lots
of ways
from single shot
to reusable
and with lots of body parts
fangs
stingers
and pincers
one venomous predator stalks the
american tropics
out of 3 000 species of centipedes it's
the leviathan
the giant centipede
[Music]
more than 11 inches long
through a pair of sharp pincers
it delivers a toxic brew of venom that
attacks the nervous system
painful to humans
lethal to prey
it's armed for defense as well as
offense with sharp hooks on the rear
legs
[Music]
it breathes partly through holes in its
body
making it prone to dehydration
so it prefers to hunt by night
[Music]
among its favorite prey are spiders
birds rodents frogs and lizards
despite its name it has 46 legs at most
not a hundred
but they grip like a mountain climber's
pitons
hmm
maybe better prospects can be found on
the ground
rodents are a favorite prey
to keep nursing her young this mother
will sooner or later have to go find
food herself
her litter is blind weak and defenseless
the centipede is nearly blind as well
but its antenna can detect the tiniest
of movements
sensing the mother's return the
centipede beats a hasty retreat
but she's too late
her baby's been killed with one
heart-stopping injection of venom
[Music]
and the centipede is off again in search
of a meal
[Music]
[Applause]
of all the predators that use venom the
most notorious may be this one
the king cobra thrives in the forests
and plains of southern asia
[Music]
his lethal venom and deadly fangs are
renowned
all take caution when he patrols the
forest knowing that a mistaken encounter
could turn deadly
in one bite it delivers more venom than
almost any other snake
enough to kill 20 men in less than an
hour
we're the biggest creature in the jungle
but the cobra's favorite food is other
snakes
that doesn't make anyone less uneasy
though
they give him plenty of room to hunt
a tree offers an excellent vantage point
to spot his next prey
and this rat snake tops the menu
the rat snake grows up to seven feet
long but carries no venom
the cobra can spot prey from nearly 300
feet
and it's found its own lunch
the rat snake detects its namesake prey
but it's unaware that it too is being
stalked
the rat is about to be rescued
by an unlikely savior
[Music]
the cobra can detect the other snake's
movement through vibrations in the
ground
but its direction finder is its tongue
[Music]
the cobra can strike from over three
feet away
the rat snake's resistance is futile
the cobra injects deadly venom through
its fangs like toxins through a pair of
hypodermics
the venom floods the rat snake's nervous
system
first comes dizziness
then sleepiness
finally
paralysis
the cobra gulps its dinner whole
[Music]
it can expand its jaws to accommodate a
super-sized meal
and its teeth also face backward to move
the meal along
digestion is already starting
venom is eating away at its victim
the rat snake may still be alive but
locked in a coma from which it will
never awaken
[Music]
it's no surprise that venom kills
but it's just part of an arsenal that
includes some of the most common and
powerful weapons in nature
[Music]
teeth
[Music]
and jaws
[Music]
for some of the world's deadliest
predators
the weapon that does all their talking
is their mouth
jaws so strong
that few victims ever escape
and so flexible they give a whole new
meaning
to open wide
the star of the summer blockbuster
the great white shark
the world's biggest flesh-eating fish
[Music]
[Applause]
its weapon of choice
up to 300 serrated steak knives which
grow right from its guns
each jaw carries several rows of deadly
blades that are replaced all throughout
its life
every eight months new teeth advance
from the back of the mouth like bullets
in an ammo belt
one of the most wide-ranging predators
it hunts in all seven seas
in waters no higher than your waist
or half a mile deep
it eats dolphins dead whales even other
great whites
but today it's going after seals
for maximum surprise and power
the shark floors the paddle
not all strikes succeed
but the shark rarely misses twice
when large prey fights back the shark
avoids injury by leaving it to bleed to
death
[Music]
once it's safe it moves in for the feast
[Music]
a great white's teeth are designed for
stabbing not chewing
it has no molars
so it grips prey and thrashes its body
twisting off flesh and swallowing it
whole
but here's why the great white is really
called jaws
a bite that may pack nearly two tons of
force 20 times the power of the human
jaw
but the creature that truly deserves the
nickname jaws doesn't inhabit the deep
the jaws of the rock python seem small
but their power speaks volumes
growing more than 20 feet long it's one
of the largest snakes in the world
[Music]
watch where you step
because the rock python will bite if
bothered
it eats almost anything it can swallow
[Applause]
[Music]
like many predators it hunts from hiding
sensors on its snap can detect whether
prey is nearby
[Music]
springbok
in a two-pronged attack the python grips
prey in its teeth
then it deploys another weapon
bondage
each time the springbok exhales the
python squeezes tighter
[Music]
every breath becomes shallower as the
python tightens its grip
until death
by strangulation
now the jaws really perform
pythons don't chew prey
they don't even dismember it
they swallow it whole starting from the
head
[Music]
jaw power makes it possible
both jaws are divided in two a total of
four moving parts
all of them flexibly attached to the
skull by tendons and ligaments
each move separately from each other
allowing the python to inhale prey three
times wider than its mouth
its teeth curve inward to keep prey from
slipping out
thanks to such flexible jaws the python
glides over its meal like a sock over a
leg
washboard muscles move prey through the
stomach
its stomach acid is so powerful it will
dissolve bone
[Music]
the python goes through one of the
longest digestions on record
and it may not eat again for a year
the next jawbreaker feeds more
frequently
it's the mighty crocodile
found lurking in the warm waters of five
continents
[Music]
it looks like an orthodontist's
nightmare
but these gnarly teeth make it one of
nature's sharpest predators
so
[Music]
the nile croc is africa's biggest
reptile and the top predator in its
rivers
it grows longer than 18 feet and weighs
more than a ton
[Music]
have the world's strongest bite
more than 5 000 pounds of force per
square inch
[Music]
they use that grip to kill prey
by holding it under water to drown
they have up to 68 teeth
shed and replaced all their lives to
keep them sharp
but the crocs jaw isn't built for
chewing
instead crocs grip the carcass and
torque their bodies to twist off flesh
the urge to migrate drives creatures
like antelope to venture into the jaws
of death
but there's no hope against a team of
hungry crocs
[Applause]
by feeding together and gripping in
unison they help dismember the carcass
mighty as those jaws are they have one
weakness
the muscles to open the jaws are so weak
you could hold them shut
if you dared try
some weapons never get used during an
attack
they're deployed before the attack
like fabric in a showroom
camouflage comes in a bewildering array
of colors and patterns
and in scales
skin
[Music]
or fur
many animals have developed some sort of
natural camouflage to either keep them
from becoming food
or to help them find food
the most clever predators have mastered
this weapon to ambush their prey
uh
chameleons use camouflage for both
offense and defense
[Music]
the newborn is vulnerable
it could make an easy meal for a snake
it seeks protection immediately
strong natural instincts guide this
master of disguise
[Music]
with a relatively thin and flat body and
skin color that can adjust to its
surroundings predators often mistake it
for either a leaf or an extension of the
tree branch
[Music]
the ruse continues when it travels
jerky back and forth movements once
again mimic a fluttering leaf
concealing it not only from predators
but also
prey
its eyes move nearly 180 degrees
independently to target prey
once in range
it strikes
camouflage is only one part of its
arsenal a chameleon's tongue is a
concealed weapon
adult chameleons can reach 27 inches in
length
and their tons may grow one and a half
times the length of their bodies
the knob like tip is coated in mucus
that sticks to prey
it strikes faster than you can see in
real time
[Music]
about 30 thousandths of a second
[Music]
the sea holds another predator both
well-armed
and well concealed
the cuttlefish
this master of disguise has the ability
to project a dazzling array of pulsating
colors
but if that weren't enough the
cuttlefish also has an extraordinary
ability to transform the shape of its
entire body
[Music]
the titan of the species is the
australian giant cuttlefish
growing nearly 20 inches long and
sometimes weighing more than 10 pounds
with such talent for camouflage the
cuttlefish can creep right up to prey
the cuttlefish prepares its main weapon
two long tentacles tipped with suction
cups that capture prey and deliver it to
a beak sharp enough to make mincemeat of
crab shell
the tentacles fire in a few hundredths
of a second
truly sudden death
some weapons are meant to be concealed
others can be brandished quite openly
claws
[Music]
they grab and grip
scratch and gouge
they're useful for digging out a meal
or taking it home
claws are the indispensable weapon of
all mammals that hunt
[Music]
especially the big cats
alliance claws are like razors
sharp and retractable
keeping them retracted protects the
claws for when they are most needed
as with all cats the lion's claws play a
key role in bringing down prey
but lions have more strength in their
paws than almost any other feline
the claws can grow up to three inches
as they get dull the outer layer sheds
revealing a sharp new cloth
[Music]
most claws are designed for climbing and
digging and catching
but some have bonus features
the pistol shrimp is no bigger than your
finger
and it's a cracked shot
one of its two claws functions just like
a handgun
and other shrimp or targets
when prey is in range
the claw is cocked
the claw snaps shut so fast
it fires a bubble bullet
up to 62 miles an hour
the bubble bursts and stuns the prey
it all happens in a fraction of a second
the fastest gun in the sea
the pistol shrimp is just one of
nature's many gunslingers
meet the sharpshooters
some prefer long-range combat for their
own safety
rather than risk injury by tangling with
prey
[Music]
others have no choice but to aim for
targets outside their element
among them these marksmen shoot a whole
battery of projectiles
[Music]
as it went its way through the
rainforest something captures this
velvet warm's attention
no it's not the fire beetles flashing
green light velvet worms are nearly
blind
but they're super sensitive to air
currents caused by movement
that's how they find their prey
and they love beetles
[Music]
the worm itself moves so slowly prey
doesn't notice it creeping up
it's packing heat
[Music]
two pistols that fire sticky ropes each
up to a foot long
this barrage of gunfire is meant to
paralyze prey with a quick drying
adhesive
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
slimed
[Music]
the worm brandishes yet another
concealed weapon
a knife in its jaw used to pierce the
body and inject saliva to liquefy the
insides
the result
a beetle milkshake
[Music]
in the struggle for survival there are
two alternatives
fight
or flight
[Music]
and one weapon covers either option
[Music]
feet
[Music]
kangaroos are vegetarians but they can
be fiercely competitive when it comes to
courting females
and when they combat each other
feet are their weapon of choice
[Music]
they're armed with extremely muscular
hind legs and enormous feet which help
them to execute broad jumps with every
hop
this bigfoot can cross the vast reaches
of the australian outback with ease
at peak speeds of almost 45 miles an
hour
but one thing can stop this speed demon
in his tracks
a potential mate
[Music]
for days during mating season a male
kangaroo also called boomer will follow
a female
he shadows her every move
[Music]
but there are plenty of boomers out
there and fights between them will break
out
often and that's when the weapons are
[Applause]
unleashed it starts with a quick right
jab
then descends into an all-out brawl
[Music]
this is not just boxing it's more like
ultimate fighting
a favorite tactic
using the four paws to grip the opponent
and then quickly kicking with their huge
clawed hind feet
it's a move that can crush bones
disembowel the opponent
even bring death
fortunately a referee breaks up this
match before it goes too far
but he can't stop the next generation of
joeys from trying some of their own
shadow boxing
nature's battlefields never fall quiet
no treaties no peace talks just an
endless arms race
weapons of mass destruction
developed over millions of years
because out here
there's no such thing as a non-combatant
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you